Set your ovens to hot and get
ready for some man-aerobics,
because we have the most
insane episode of "1984" yet.
A lot of our theories have come true,
so I'm here to break it all down and
what it could mean for episodes to come.
You'll want to stick around to the very end to
see how this season could link to "Apocalypse".
Now let's get into it.
Episode 4: "True Killers"
starts sometime in the near past
where Montana has a quick
pick-me-up before starting her class.
We're at the Perfect 10 Aerobics Studio,
the same one we saw in episode 1.
A not creepy at all Ricky Ramirez
watches from the window,
and he either really
likes men doing aerobics,
or something else has drawn him in.
When he enters, it's almost as if a combination
of the music and Satan have led him to Montana,
who's quick to notice his knife.
Ricky is training as well, just not his cardio.
Montana steps into the locker alone, 'cause you know, it's man-aerobics and she's the only woman there.
only to find the gutted
corpse of the Cyndi Lauper fan.
And instead of screaming and running
the hell away, she is kind of turned on by it.
Notice how he's strung up by these cords, the
same that can be found on Ricky's belt here.
And Ricky goes to town on her feet.
They engage in some post-coital pillow talk,
which includes arranging the murder of Brooke.
And yes, as I predicted in my last video,
Montana is the brother of Sam,
the best man at
Brooke's ill-fated wedding.
She believes Brooke lied about hooking
up with Sam the night before the wedding,
an event which caused
Joseph to kill him.
Now she's hell-bent on revenge,
and Ricky is the one to do her bidding.
Back in the present, Montana
chastises Ricky for not killing Brooke.
Remember, he's had two opportunities
to do it, and she's gotten away each time.
She tells them that they have to
do it fast, since Jingles is around,
and then they'll make their escape.
Trevor and Xavier have somehow
managed to get Chet out of that pit of spikes
and made their way back to the infirmary.
Nope, no, he doesn't.
After he passes out, they decide
to hit him with some adrenaline,
which apparently is
some really good shit.
He tells them that Ray killed
someone in college and Xavier is like,
which reminds him that Blake's Cadillac,
that porn producer we met in episode 2,
is still somewhere nearby.
If they can get Margaret and Bertie and make
their way back to the car, they have a way out.
So Trevor and Xavier decide to split up
and look for them, leaving Chet all alone.
What could go wrong?
And I love how they just give Chet a pair
of scissors like, thanks ... thanks guys.
Margaret finds the dead pranksters from
last episode, which really can't be good news,
considering campers are
expected tomorrow morning.
Trevor tries to get her to leave,
but she's gone full crazy and says
everything's gonna be
okay because she has a gun,
the same gun we saw at
the beginning of episode 2.
Now when she touches the blood on
the body here, she gets a quick flashback.
Is it from her surviving the massacre
or having done the massacre?
We'll get to that in a bit.
Xavier heads over to the mess hall,
and bonus points if you picked up
that AHS alum Stevie Nicks
is playing on the radio.
Bertie's there making sandwiches in the dark, because you know, that's what you do, when Jingles comes in.
Xavier hides under the bench, and we
learn a little more about Margaret here.
Bertie called her a "weird kid"
and says that she lives in the past
and wants to be here for Margaret to help
her turn the page with Camp Redwood's revival.
Xavier is a total ding-dong and drops his
flashlight, alerting Jingles to his presence.
Bertie tries to save them
but both are knocked out.
And of course, it would be great if Xavier
revealed himself as Michael Langdon now
so he could survive the heat.
Brooke wakes up in some sort of shed after
she was drugged last episode by nurse Rita.
Or should I say psychologist Donna Chambers?
Remember that Rita and Jingles are working
together, and that she was instrumental in his escape.
Now Brooke is able to
get out of the shed pretty easy,
but it doesn't take long for her
to spring one of those forest trap.
Last episode, I predicted that it was Rita who set these up, since she would have had time, unlike Jingles,
to prepare the grounds
for their upcoming arrival.
In episode 2 when Jingles visits her, she
would have likely told him where all the traps are,
so he could both avoid them
himself and capture more victims.
Rita spills the beans and tells Brooke her
entire plan and uses Brooke as bait for Jingles.
Will Jingles kill indiscriminately or
does he need the thrill of the hunt?
Last episode, we saw him leave the chubby
prankster when he could have easily killed him,
so his motives to
kill are still unknown.
And rest in peace,
Xavier's beautiful porn career,
I swear if we have to watch Cody Fern with
blisters in his face for the next six episodes,
I'm not gonna be impressed.
"Ma face!"
With her dying strength, Bertie
helps Xavier out of the oven,
and in an act of mercy,
Xavier puts her out of her misery.
"Chef Bertie is good people!"
And great, his fingerprints
are gonna be all over that knife.
Montana is outen aboot - yes, I'm Canadian -
looking for Brooke, when she finds her in the trap.
Brooke tells her all about Rita, I mean Donna,
when Montana says to hang tight while
she gets her something sharp to cut her down.
*cough, cough* Ricky.
Margaret checks her gun,
when we're given this absolutely insane
flashback of her and Jingles from 1970.
Notice the three counselors
here who make fun of her,
who are the same counselors
from the episode 1 massacre.
She's given a bear carving by
Jingles as a symbol of strength,
then she goes on to say this weird
fact that bears mate for life, and
oh, oh god, what are you doing, please, no.
Ricky makes a pentagram, seeking
guidance from the master, Satan,
when Montana directs
him where to find Brooke.
Jingles arrives before
Ricky can touch Brooke,
and it seems as though he might have
a thing for saving defenseless women.
But the most intriguing thing about this
scene is what Ricky says about the camp,
saying that the blood
spilled in this place is eternal,
and no matter which way you
slice it, Mr. Jingles lives forever.
He's alluding to immortality, and
with his death through Jingles here,
and the fact we've seen characters
like the hitchhiker come back to life,
it's no wonder he comes
back at the end of the episode.
During the scuffle, Rita and Montana
fight, and Brooke manages to get away.
Margaret's here, praying for
Cody Fern to get his burns healed,
when she's confronted by Jingles.
And we finally get confirmation
that she was the murderer all along.
We get this flashback
of Jingles being arrested
and his Vietnam ammo canister filled with
severed ears that were planted by Margaret.
Here in Jingles' cabin, we can see her
plant the ears, which also includes her own.
This bitch took off her own damn ear!
Also little thing, Jingles
also carved a cute bunny.
(Chorus) Aww.
Margaret proceeds to tell him the truth
about what happened all those years ago.
The amount of drugs and electroshock
therapy he went through made him forget.
He had promised to protect her
from the bullies but did nothing,
so she took matters into her own
hands - literally, by killing everyone,
making Jingles take the fall.
Enraged by this revelation, Jingles
goes to kill Margaret but is shot by him.
Remember what Ricky said: Jingles is eternal.
Brooke, Trevor, and Chet meet up,
having heard the gunshots,
and for a guy who's
almost been killed a bunch,
he makes sure to tell Montana, who just rolled
around in the dirt fighting Rita, how gorgeous she is.
What's going on, ladies, you are really
manipulating men this season.
Although my favorite part of this scene is when Trevor tells Montana to take Chet, this bitch rolls our eyes!
Anyways, Trevor's off to look for Margaret
and - oh, oh no, this this can't go over well.
Trevor sees that she's
killed Jingles, but it's too late.
Margaret stabs Trevor,
having gone full psychopath.
She takes off his ear, once again to
make it look like it was Jingles all along.
And speaking of which, he's disappeared.
As if Xavier night couldn't get any
worse, he stumbles into Jingles,
and his weak ass tries to stab him.
But we get this line from Jingles,
which could mean two things: either he's still
processing the revelation that he wasn't the killer,
or that it was actually Margaret
who stabbed Bertie to death
and threw Xavier in the oven
when they were both unconscious.
I'll leave that one up
for you guys to decide.
Brooke rushes in and Jingles has
once again mysteriously disappeared,
almost like he has some
sort of teleportation power.
They see an explosion off in the distance, which we
find is their only means of escape: Blake's Cadillac.
This is gonna be really tough to
clean up before the kids arrive.
Margaret tells them that Jingles attacked
her and Trevor died in the process,
leaving the rest to process how
they're gonna get out of this mess.
And now we have the coolest WTF moment of
the episode: the resurrection of Ricky Ramirez.
Rita awakens from getting clobbered in
the head to find Ricky levitating in the air
and his wounds magically healing.
I don't know about you guys,
but I got some "Exorcist" vibes here.
He looks as though he's possessed, you
can hear whispers of people saying "Satan",
and that combined with the levitation.
But more interesting are his black eyes.
Now, where did I see that again?
I think this is huge proof that we're gonna see a bigger connection between this season and "Apocalypse".
And if there's a connection to "Apocalypse",
there's probably a connection to "Coven".
Now it's a bit too early to say
what exactly this connection is,
whether they are somehow
related or simply guided by Satan,
but it sure would have been handy for
Papa Satan to resurrect his own son last season.
As with many AHS seasons,
a lot of it comes down to taste,
but this one is shaping up
to be one of my favorites.
Let's hope Ryan Murphy
and the team can keep it up.
Make sure to like and subscribe with the bell on,
because I'll be coming out with more AHS videos.
And leave a comment about what
you think about the season below
or send me theories
on Twitter @ThinkStoryYT.
Until next time remember,
Daddy loves you very much.